III 2020 is canceled which means no
press conferences from Sony Microsoft
and Nintendo at least not on the way
we're used to getting them so what are
they gonna do now coronavirus concerns
have put the city of Los Angeles in a
state of emergency leading to the
cancellation of gaming's biggest annual
convention so without a physical III
space to accommodate companies the big
publishers that normally deliver press
conferences are looking at alternative
methods to make their biggest
announcements to you Sony pulled out of
a three earlier this year before any
virus concerns came to the surface
saying it would use other events
throughout 2020 to deliver its messages
this leaves Microsoft Nintendo and more
publishers in question the Microsoft
theater is adjacent to the LA Convention
Center so Microsoft's certainly has the
opportunity to broadcast some sort of
presentation from that space for its
part Microsoft will hold a quote Digital
Xbox event the company has said we
should expect to hear more about that in
the coming weeks Nintendo was vague in
its response saying its quote
considering various ways to engage with
fans Nintendo has had a booth on the e3
show floor for numerous years but it's
been skipping the traditional press
conference in favor of scripted
pre-recorded Nintendo directs in terms
of announcements another live stream
direct is most likely though as of yet
it son confirmed more companies beyond
just Microsoft and Nintendo are making
new plans in lieu of the show's
cancellation though Ubisoft said that it
supports the ESA s decision to cancel
the show and it's looking at quote other
options for a digital experience Square
Enix is also quote exploring other
options to deliver its news devolver
digital and limited run games will be
holding livestream press conferences
limited run games will air Monday June
8th at 3 p.m. Eastern of course there
are more companies than those we just
named that are moving to Plan B in light
of III is cancellation so stay tuned a
game spot for more updates from these
publishers as they roll in the show must
go on
you
[Music]